la bcl a pas été supprimée de gens
pensent que j'aurais dû normalement ne
pas avoir à repayer cette année mais
visiblement c'est pas le cas donc j'ai
payé même si ça a baissé j'ai quand même
payer la taxe d'habitation
elle a été supprimée en totalité et je
trouve ça excellent bon c'est vrai que
les communes ont besoin de la taxe
d'habitation pour divers projets mais en
tant que particulier c'est vrai qu'on
apprécie moi je payais très lourd je
suis sur la commune de bois d'arcy et
c'est vrai que sur mon budget belge
apprécie quoi la taxe d'habitation pour
moi en effet elle a bien diminué par
contre c'est la taxe audiovisuelle qui a
augmenté
bah ce que j'en pense ça fait toujours
du bien aux portefeuilles de payer moins
cher ma taxe d'habitation n'a pas baissé
encore puisque mais heureusement pour
moi je fais partie des revenus élevés
je pense que c'est une bonne chose parce
qu'on paie déjà beaucoup de d'impôt sur
l'immobilier
donc ce sera une bonne chose mais je
n'ai pas encore vu sur la feuille
d'impôts de la conséquence je pense que
payer moins de taxes en france et 1
passe et toujours bien donc c'est
toujours bienvenu qu'on nous laisse un
peu les taxes dans notre quotidien